Today we discuss timing issues in
contract formation by examining an English
contract case from the 19th
century Adams versus Lin.
Saul was decided by the
Court of Kings bench in 1818.
The Court of Kings bench or Queen's bench,
uh,
was an English court of common law.
While this might seem like
an obsolete English case,
it created an important common law rule.
The mailbox rule.
That's what it stands for,
which teaches us when a mailed
acceptance acceptance forms of contract.
In this case,
the defendant Lynn Zelle,
was a wool dealer looking to sell wool.
He sent a letter to the plaintiff
buyer Adams offering to sell.
We'll add a specified price
to be delivered at a light
Chester and to be paid
for by two months. Bill
in two months. However,
the defendant miss directed this letter.
In other words,
he wrote down the wrong address and it
took longer than expected for the letter
to reach the plaintiff.
By the time the plaintiff got the
letter and sent back his acceptance,
it was two days after the
expected deadline for acceptance.
Unfortunately, by that time, the
defendant had already sold that wool.
The plaintiff sues the seller
for nondelivery of wool.
If you're still a bit confused,
let's quickly review the
chronology of events on Tuesday,
September 2nd the seller sends
the offer to the wrong address.
It takes a whole three days
before reaching the buyer.
The buyer sends the acceptance on Friday,
September 5th and it doesn't reach the
seller until the following Tuesday.
By that time,
the seller had already sold the wool.
The trial court found
for plaintiffs afterward,
defendant wins a rule Nisi order
that there is no binding contract.
A rule Nisi is an order in case you're
wondering that may or may not have forest
depending on whether a particular
condition is satisfied.
It's from the Latin word Nisi.
That means unless in this case the
condition is unless the plaintiff can show
cause.
The plaintiff's lawyers show cause and
trial judgment for plaintiff is affirmed.
The main issue in this case is whether
the plaintiff's acceptance is valid.
When uh, it was mailed,
the court held that yes,
the acceptance is valid
the moment it was mailed,
the court reasoned that if it opted for
the other rule that acceptance is valid.
When the offer offer roar receives it,
then the plaintiffs,
uh,
except doors ought not to be bound until
after they had received notification
that the defendant had received
their answer and the sent it to it.
And so it might go on Ad Infinitum,
the court reasons that would be a bad
result because it would lead to an
infinite chain of correspondence
confirming that the other person knew.
The court realize that when a
contract is formed at a distance,
either the offer or war or the acceptor
will not be able to know precisely when
the contract is formed.
In this case,
the defendant offer or was responsible
for the misdirected letter and hence for
the predicament of contracting
to sell the wool twice.
The so called mailbox rule
suggested by this case applies.
However, even when there is
no misdirected initial offer,
the rural can be found in
restatement of contract, uh, uh,
section 63 a that provision states that
acceptance occurs as soon as it leaves
the offer. Rees
possession. In other words,
the moment you put the acceptance in
the mail box and can't take it back,
the contract takes effect.
Uh,
there are a few justifications
for the mailbox rule.
A key reason is that the
rule is merely a default.
The offer war can always stipulate
that communication is required before a
contract formation.
You can see that from the first sentence
of section 63 a which specifies the
rule is binding unless the
offer provides otherwise
under the mailbox rule the offer or
is the last to know whether and when a
contract is formed.
Uh,
but any offer or who doesn't like the
result is free as master of her offer to
say that the offer will only be accepted
when notice of acceptance is received
by the offer or section 63 sets the
timing default against the party who is
empowered to alter it.
Another justification is that after
posting the seller is in the best position
to know of a delay and to inquire all
of this is aimed at protecting and offer
re who does what is reasonable to ascent
and assuming there is a contract relies
on it.
Furthermore,
requiring more confirmation
does not reduce mistake.
It just shifts the
burden to the other side.
The last person to confirm will always
be at an informational disadvantage
because she will not know whether
her confirmation got through.
Requiring more confirmations is
probably a waste of social resources.
The finding of contract at
time of dispatch that the
formation occurs when it's
sent means the offeree may safely rely
without inquiring as to whether there was
a dispatched but uncommunicated
revocation. Thus,
as long as the offeree selects a
reasonable method of communicating ascent,
he or she should be able to rely
on the formation of a contract.
Was the holding and Adams versus
Lynn Cell and exact iteration of the
justifications of the mailbox
rule? Well, not exactly,
although this case is
thought to be the origin, uh,
of the so called mailbox rule.
The holding seems to be that because
the seller misdirected the offer,
he should be bound by the acceptance
that would have arrived in due course of
post.
In short,
the seller expected to hear
from the buyer on September 7th,
so there was no need to discuss the
effect of the posting of the letter.
That question would be posed if
the offer had not been misdirected.
The buyer posted in acceptance and the
seller sells the wool to a third party
and then the acceptances arrived.
Let's,
let's take a look at the scope
of the mailbox rule first.
What if the offer acceptance
is never received?
Say it gets stolen or destroyed in
a tragic mail delivery van fire,
there's still a contract.
In that case,
the offer bares the risk of non delivery.
If the offer doesn't
want to bear that risk,
she can again contract around it and say
that the contract is only formed when
the acceptances received.
Finally,
what about other mediums of communication?
The mailbox rule has been
applied to telegrams,
faxes and and other mediums
of contractual communication.
It's when they're sent that the
acceptance becomes effective. Nowadays,
more and more contracting is done
by electronic transmissions where
communication is virtually instantaneous.
The sending and receipt happens almost
simultaneously under such circumstances.
There's a good reason for holding that
an acceptance is only effective when
received and not when transmitted.
The authors of an influential study
observed that an important premise upon
which the mailbox rule is predicated
is the notion of some delayed medium of
communication such as mailbox, uh, uh,
uh, writings and they do
not provide either party,
the ability to verify in a timely fashion
that receipt of a message has occurred
and that the message has
received is without error. Hence,
these authors have maintained
that electronic transmission
should be governed by
the same rules that apply when parties
are in each other's presence. Uh,
and the acceptance should
be deemed effective only
when received and confirmed.
Acceptance is not the only
act that causes timing issues,
offers counter offers and
revocations also post timing issues.
However,
every other formation act becomes
effective at the time it's received,
not at the time that it is sent.
Why our offers counteroffers and
revocations treated differently?
Well,
maybe because these rules
are also defaults that are
set against the person who
has a unilateral power to opt out.
What about from offers?
That is option contracts.
A restatement.
Section 63 provides that an acceptance
under an option contract is not effective
until received by the offer or
in the view of the drafters.
Since the option contract provides
for irrevocability of the offer.
The primary reason for the rule of
Adams versus Linzille and its progeny is
absent.
The position suggests that the mailbox
rule is employed to protect the
[inaudible] opportunity to make a
sound decision against an unexpected
revocation in option contracts
and for a and from offers,
there's no threat of offer or revocation,
so the mailbox rule does not
make sense in those contexts.
So let's imagine this.
Robert offers to sell Sally a box of
jewelry for $10,000 Sally accepts by
sending a letter and putting it in the
mail while the letter is in the mail.
Robert Call Sally to tell
her the offer is revoked.
Is there a contract?
The answer is yes.
Under section 42 revocation is
not effective until the offer.
He receives a manifestation of this
revocation from the offer or interestingly
that this may not even be a default,
might be a mandatory rule of timing.
The mailed acceptance creates the
contract and the revocation has no legal
consequence because it was not manifested
until after the acceptance became
effective and only uh, it has only
received after the contract was formed.
Also note that section 40 creates a
limited exception to the mailbox rule when
the sending of an acceptance is
proceeded by a previous sending of a
counteroffer or revocation.
Section.
40 in effect says a letter or telegram
of acceptance dispatched after the
sending of another wise,
uh,
affective rejection or counter offer
only operates as an acceptance if the
acceptance is received by the offer or
before she receives the rejection or
counter offer.
Or to put it even more simply,
if an offeree has previously
sent a counteroffer or rejection,
the acceptance will only
take place if at all,
at the time of receipt to see how this
works. Imagine the following scenario.
On Day One B receives A's offer.
On Day two B sends a counteroffer and
then on day three B sends an acceptance.
Now if it weren't for section 40 there
would be an acceptance of an offer here
because the counter offer only becomes
effective when it's received and the
acceptance would have occurred here,
but section 40 a
complicates this analysis.
There are two possibilities about when
the counter offer and acceptance will be
received.
If a receives the acceptance
before the counter offer,
then there's going to be a
contract because acceptance
under this condition will
occur when it is received,
but under the second possibility
a receives the counteroffer first,
which blows up the offer and renders
ineffective the subsequent receipt of the
acceptance. And so under this second
possibility there would be no contract.
Finally, let's discuss what
constitutes reasonable acceptance.
As we discussed earlier,
the mailbox rule applies when the method
of acceptance is a reasonable response
under the circumstances.
The next example will help us see
what reasonable acceptance might mean.
So imagine in July,
1990 Carol was hired as a
special education teacher
by the Huron School district
for the 1990 [inaudible] 91 school year.
On August 15th,
1990 Carol handed to Ed her supervisor
a letter of resignation effective on
August 17th.
You should think of this
letter as an offer to uh,
enter employment.
In the letter she requested that her final
check be mailed to an address some 50
miles away which was her parents' home.
Ed gave the letter to Mary,
the superintendent,
the superintendent for the school
who had authority to hire and fire.
On August 20th that same day,
Mary prepared and mailed the letter
properly addressed to Carol at her parents
accepting the resignation.
The next day,
Carol hand delivered a letter to
Mary withdrawing her resignation.
Mary told Carol that the resignation had
been accepted and handed her a copy of
the letter mailed the day before.
That letter did not reach Carol's
parents home until August 24th.
Carol claims that the resignation had
been withdrawn in time because the
acceptance letter should
have been handed to her.
Let's first sink through some of strongest
arguments for the school district.
In other words,
arguments for why Carol resignation
offer was properly accepted.
The school district could argue that Carol
handed her written offer to resign to
a supervisor who forwarded to the person
with the power to accept and given the
dates involve three days after when
Carol said her resignation was effective.
Uh,
and the assumption that Carol would be
at her parents posting the acceptance
would appear to be reasonable and the
mirror posting under the mailbox rule
should have been the
time where the, um, uh,
resignation offer was accepted.
Here.
The manner in which the offer is
communicated is not determinative.
Thus the resignation would be
effective at the time they posted,
uh, the letter. But what if
Carol had sent a telegram,
a of offering to resign and Mary had
merely sent a letter accepting that offer
before the letter arrived.
Carol revoked the resignation by email.
In that case,
Carol's initial manner of communication,
a telegram might signal what form
a reasonable response might take.
Mary arguably should have known that
Carol was expecting a prompt apply.
Sending a letter on these facts was,
would not be reasonable.
They're reasonable response
was to telegraph or email
that the resignation was
accepted.
Finally,
what if Carol had telephone berry and
left the offer to resign on Mary's
voicemail?
And what if Carol had used a fax?
How should marry except in those cases?
Well,
the use of voicemail and Telefax is
common and suggests at least that Mary May
use the same mode for acceptance.
The response doesn't have to be faster,
but at least there's an argument
that the mode of acceptance, uh,
shouldn't come through a
slower mode of communication.
It might mean that these attempts to
accept by a slower mode are not effective
because they're not reasonable or
that they wouldn't be effective until
received.
So any overtaking revocation of the
offer would render the acceptance in
ineffective.
In summary,
the mailbox rule states that acceptance
takes effect when an acceptance is
placed out of the offer.
Rees possession.
This is in contrast to offers revocations
and counter offers which only take
effect at the time they are received.
However,
while the mailbox rule
has a fairly wide scope,
it does not apply in cases where the mess,
that method of acceptance
is not reasonable,
such as responding to an
email, uh, with snail mail.